what's the deal with airplane
peanuts Hans Kim is about to fight this
man for his spot on Kil Tony Rick Diaz
who for two weeks in a row keeps
dropping your for no
reason but the New Year's Eve show is
also going to include golden ticket
winners performing in front of massive
crowds and a notable list of Highly
anticipated guest appearances all while
being the first ever live podcast to be
recorded in an arena unbelievable he's
doing this podcast in an arena on New
Year's Eve congratulations that's
[__] amazing so much and although Kil
Tony typically turns to Joe Rogan to
co-host their special events there's a
growing Theory amongst comedy fans
pointing to new Austin residents Matt
mccusker and Shane Gillis as the more
likely option for the surprise panel
members now that you guys are here you
and Shane on kill Tony at the same time
literally the most requested guest in
the history of the show it's been the
last 2 years you guys really uh I don't
want to give any secrets away but it
might be an extra extra big one that we
get you guys on it'll be a lot of fun
dude that would be a [__] blast so
who should comedy fans expect to see on
New Year's Eve are other members of the
show rooting for Rick or Hans and what
does it really feel like to be a young
comedian preparing for your biggest show
ever to answer all these questions and
more we're joined today by three of kill
Tony's most viral Sensations cam
Patterson Rick Diaz and Heath Cordes cam
Patterson thank you so much for joining
the show today ahead of the Tony arena
show at HB Arena coming up on New Year's
Eve ahead of this big kill Tony show
coming up what is the largest crowd
you've performed in front of up to now
Tony take me on the RO do theater stuff
so the theater that we've been doing
probably the biggest is like like 4,000
3,000 something like
that the biggest number right now is
life changing to like know you want to
do something real bad and to be able to
do it every week it's like it's it's
it's it's just a real feeling well Heath
we're talking to you a few weeks before
the kill Tony arena show up to this
point Point what is the largest crowd
you've ever performed in front of so far
yeah so just recently about a month ago
I got to go on Tony or tour with Tony
for a little bit and I did about 3,000
seats Dam in Phoenix and so that was
really helpful I'm glad I got that
because before I got to do those shows
with Tony it was only about 400 so I
can't even imagine going from 400 to
8,000 we've heard a lot about what it
feels like to perform at the Mothership
interviewing various comedians but you
also work there what is that experience
like it's like the coolest job ever you
feel what I'm saying I I have some jobs
but it just like feel like college you
know saying I a't never went to college
so kind of meeting all the big comedian
like that while I'm on the clock and
like I mean cuz being a door guys like
that's a big thing bro like working
there is like one of it's one of the
best experiences I've had like as a
person I'm saying do you feel more
connected to the Kil Tony family or or
the mothership family or does that all
blend into one it all one family yeah
it's all one big you know I'm saying it
just got different like you know like
cous [__] one it's one big ass family
yeah for sure it's no different
everybody in there like I call man she
like my mom you feel what I'm saying
like that that that place the reason I
didn't get homesick real quick like I've
been there like n months I I ain't get
hom sick cuz it feel like home you feel
me well your old home is here in Florida
I'm based out of Tampa right now but you
got a lot of people coming in from
Florida to Austin what is that like
everyone kind of following your
footsteps and and expecting you to take
him to the promised land in this new
comedy Mecca I mean it's cool I just
like to show people like that I think
it's really funny like you if you want
to come out here it's it's show it's
stage time Ain no ain't no greenness in
my heart you know saying this place
Chang my life so I would like other
people that I uh that I'm really cool
with or I think it's very funny you know
saying too you feel me because it's so
it's so much day time a gonna hurt me to
have a home but I'm cooling on the you
know I'm saying so much [__] going on so
you've been able to spend some more time
in Austin since we last spoke make some
more appearance on the show how has this
crazy kill Tony ride been for you since
the last appearance that you've made on
joke world yeah it's been so much fun
I've meting so many cool people and I've
done a lot of cool things like I said I
got to go and do my first theaters with
Tony and that's an experience I'll never
forget speaking of that first interview
there's a lot of people who commented on
that video saying well wait about the
whole uh bucket being rigged thing
they're like how did Shane Gillis get to
talk to you before you went on stage if
this is not set up all that stuff do you
want to clarify exactly how that
happened like you get pulled and you
wait a little bit behind the stage yeah
I mean if they watch the episode they
would know how it makes sense I mean he
lives in Austin now and that's like the
coolest Club in the city so of course
he's there all the time and he was just
backstage it was all just a coincidence
there's a battle for regular ship
happening at this New Year's Eve show
though between Hans Kim and Rick Diaz so
as a regular yourself are you leaning
towards anyone in this matchup do you
have a personal favorite to win oh win
man got this you know I'm saying bad my
brother man do do you guys all as
regulars have a special connection back
there because you are the only ones that
have to do a new minute every single
week really no one else in comedy has
been in these shoes where every single
week in Fr of millions of people you got
to get a new Fresh 60 seconds yeah we
turn into family bro them like I'm like
my big brother especially like going
from you know saying somebody who it
took me a little longer to write jokes
you say I like to cultivate it and try
to make it as strong as I can from going
to like where every week I just got to
push something man like my big br you
know what I'm saying like H and William
and and Montgomery they just made a lot
easier for the transition you know what
I'm saying so yeah it's it's Hans Kim to
to the death me the main event is going
to be Hans Kim vers Rick Diaz as you
know and as a fellow golden ticket
winner do you have a favorite going into
this matchup or anyone you're pulling
for no I'm really excited to see how
it's going to turn out I think the drama
is really cool it does a lot for the
show so it's fun to watch was it
interesting at all to win your golden
ticket during the same time that all
this drama was going on with another
golden ticket winner challenging
regulars was that weird happening at the
same time and did it give you any ideas
of your own it's neat to be a part of it
while all this is happening but um not
really any ideas I'm just going to keep
using my ticket I'm happy with where I'm
at right now yeah and as a fellow golden
ticket winner do you have a favorite
going into this matchup or anyone you're
pulling for no I'm really excited to see
how it's going to turn out I think the
drama is really cool it does a lot for
the show so it's fun to watch so we are
here with Rick Diaz ahead of his matchup
with Hans Kim in the kill Tony arena
show you're getting to perform in the HB
arena for the first time and up to this
point I'm wondering Rick what is the
largest crowd you've ever performed in
up to now uh 3 to 400 so does this arena
show intimidate you at all because of
the crowd size or is it just going to be
businesses normal I will only know how
intimidated I am when I get there that's
true but I'm I'm expecting to be
intimidated as hell not necessarily by
the crowd size that kind of like I'm
really excited to perform for a huge
crowd that's something that's you know
it's you know I could only dream about
it a few months ago but it's mostly like
how am I supposed to manage my timing
how am I going to perform for this kind
of crowd a local crowd how is it going
to go yeah so I'm very curious but also
nervous about it yeah of course how has
the beef online with Hans evolved since
the last time we spoke it's evolved it's
evolved uh he has uh I guess we've been
uh in different ways trolling each other
to for a while I think it's gone very
quite pretty quiet on both fronts lately
I I posted a couple of things he posted
a few things he had MC Vader do posters
for for his solo shows using my face and
name and uh that was interesting then I
reposted that then he gave me a strike
down copyright notice on Instagram so I
screenshotted that and posted his notice
which I know is from from him because it
said his hands came with his hands him
email you know what I mean so like I I
knew it was directly from him and then
but he still has blocked me but somehow
things get to him or he reopens his
Instagram from time to time to check
things I don't know he's been uh
insulting fans of mine that put comments
about me on his channel it's just like
it's being I don't know I I don't think
he's enjoying the the whole thing so and
and I could understand why he doesn't
enjoy it I'm I don't want to push too
many buttons but I did enjoy the back
and forth I wish it had been a little
more fun I wish he was able to take the
joke but he's taking it incredibly
seriously and I hope that translates
into him finally writing some good jokes
for that show have you received any push
back from longtime kill Tony fans who
are a little angry at you for
potentially knocking off a future Hall
of Fame regular out of the show
completely first of all there's Tony
already said one of us might be
temporarily banned from the show so like
we don't know the consequences the
consequences is I will lose my golden
ticket and I have the feeling that will
be not temporary if I lose which is
likely to happen if H loses he'll get to
do other things for a bit and I'm sure
at some point he'll come back you know
what I mean there's he's a he's a he is
a Kil Tony Hall of Famer for a good
reason he's earned that right to be
named that if if that even existed but
you know like he's earned like the love
of the fans and he's collected that over
you know months and months and months
and months and months of working hard
for that show yeah I've got a little
push back some people are you know like
well you're confident but you pretended
not to be confident you you're not as
good as him like well I'm four years in
or five four to five years in I'm
performing fraction of what he can
perform because there's less comedy here
where I am I have a day job so with that
being said I think I'm doing pretty good
I think I made an impression I'm
receiving loads of love and I'm
receiving way more love than I'm
receiving hate from some idiots and I've
also noticed that a some of the people
that were confronting me the moment I
talk talk to them they're like no I
actually like you I just like h a lot
and I was like yeah so so a lot of it is
also like just online trolling but
they're humans I'm human I don't really
care I just want to have a good show and
I definitely am trying to come to win
well you mentioned that you're still
working a full-time job if you did win
on New Year's Eve what is your plan to
leave this full-time job I believe it's
with the government it's of some
importance and move to America to become
the kill Tony regular if I even if I
lose the battle that doesn't mean that I
can't perform in America or have a
career in America thanks to Kil Tony and
thanks to Tony hinchliff like my uh and
the opportunity he's given me and my
profile has risen a
lot I I don't think this battle will
make or break my ability to for people
like for Bookers of clubs to want to
book me like whether I win or lose is am
I funny and do I draw do I put do I sell
seats that's are the only things that
matter right so of course winning
becoming a regular onkill Tony is a big
deal because of the continued exposure
it gives you so that's that so that does
help raise a profile in the medium to
longer term how has your experience been
with American Comedy in general like the
fans getting involved uh you know
starting to interact with you some more
just everything that you've seen since
becoming you know on this scene how has
that been all in all my numbers even
though they're much bigger now in terms
of following they are still small you
know but my experience has been for the
most part just incredibly positive well
Rick sadman Rick on Instagram anything
else that you want to leave the people
with before we see you battle Hans Kim
this is your last chance to get out any
sort of message prediction message to
the fans message to Hans to all the
people that think that I should have
settled because I won a golden ticket
and then I shouldn't go out for more
just know that from Europe a golden
ticket is pretty much
unusable and second of all to for people
that complain that I'm going after
somebody's job for my current job I had
to beat about 3,000 applicants for every
job I've had in my entire life as a
working man I've had inter interviews
and tests and exams against hundreds and
dozens or whatever other many people
anybody that has a job has had to take
that job off of somebody else H got his
job handed to him and it just so happens
that he's getting some competition so
deal with it like a grownup like an
American man would and like a man
anywhere in the world would man or woman
or any other gender if you work somebody
else is not getting your job it's how it
is I'm sorry and if I lose this battle
I'm gonna have a hell of a ton of fun
getting that thing done that got me
fired that made no sense but it almost
made sense that was a locker room speech
I'm I'm ready to watch this battle go
down right now it's seem we even have to
wait a few days but thank you so much
for your time today Rick it's always a
pleasure chatting with you talking
comedy talking kill Tony and no matter
what happens with this battle you're
always welcome on this show so hope to
see you again me again you'll have to
have me again cuz H is still not going
to do it so he's a media coward that
should at least do something to promote
this thing I made him a main event at
this show before I came on kill Tony he
would have been just one more minute on
that show and because I made a hell of a
ton of a big ass promotion for this
thing he's he just became the main event
so yeah hkim you're a more experienced
better funnier nicer more Cher comedian
than I am but without me you would have
just been a regular both Rick and Heath
are now recurring joke World guests so
be sure to check out their other
interviews on this channel for even more
golden ticket stories and another
interesting part about these Kil Tony
Arena shows there's been so much demand
to see this thing live that they
actually added a second show at HB Arena
meaning there's a chance that there's
multiple sets of guest appearances and
maybe even two separate YouTube uploads
a few weeks later guest spots from last
week The Joe Rogan Experience had a solo
Shane gills episode episode as well as a
protect our Parks wheeler Walker Jr
visited your mom's house stos hus was a
guest on tiger belly two bears one cave
was Burton Tom Tom and Bert Tom sagoro
went on you know what dude Tom was also
a guest right here on joke World aru
garbage and the Tim Dylan show did not
have guests Aon Bronson went on flagrant
and the duo of hoe Mandel and Sam Talent
went on Matt and Shane secret podcast
you were on a special bus no I like the
thing you do about your is it your
nephew uh Uncle your uncle I love that
thank you that's a that's brilliant
thank you very much and I just love your
facial expressions and yeah I got it
it's an easy uh it's not difficult for
me to morph him that isn't that I find
that I couldn't stop there it is
switching I really have code
switching that'd be funny if we did that
you know there's podcasts that sometimes
you know they use PL I don't know if you
know this we switched in just
like you try to eat the statue this past
weekend with Theo Von spoke with Kat Von
D steo was on first date Steve was also
on take your shoes off Jim Jeff was on
the Blox podcast Chris Stefano visited
stav's world we might be drunk talked
with Joe D roza Keith Robinson and
Marina Franklin Jimmy Carr was on
Chrissy chaos taste buds battled
leftovers with Todd Barry being in with
Jordan welcome the stuff Island Boys
whiskey Ginger talked with Justin Wilman
Aaron Berg and M fox were on the Legion
of skanks and the honeydude talked with
Mike veon as far as new stand-up comedy
specials that are either out right now
or coming out soon Josh Wolf here for
the fun is a full 90 minute special out
on his YouTube channel and a few other
specials out on YouTube Shane Torres the
blue-eyed Mexican is on Berke Cher's
Channel Carmen Lynch queef week is on
the Mark Norman Channel and Mike Baldwin
has a new special out on 800lb gorilla
titled number one top selling best
comedy special ever which is a title
that's not only great for SEO but also
describes Mike's sense of humor
perfectly and a few specials in the
works right now that will be coming out
soon from two of the most famous
comedians in the world December 25th
Ricky Jase Armageddon will be coming out
out on Netflix then just one week after
that Dave Chappelle's new special will
also be premiering on Netflix speaking
of famous comedians on Netflix Pete
Davidson will be releasing his second
special on the platform this January
titled turbo Fonzerelli and some sadder
news to end this week's episode perhaps
the greatest sitcom of all time Curb
Your Enthusiasm has announced this
upcoming season will be their last I
guess in a lot of ways it makes sense
because Larry's getting pretty pretty
old and they've already given us 12
amazing Seasons but it still sucks to
see this show go and after the Seinfeld
finale sparked Decades of debate I'm
sure all eyes will be on the last
episode of curb to see how LD wraps up
one of the most prolific comedic writing
careers we've ever seen please consider
subscribing to joke world right now to
stay in the loop with all of your
favorite comedians and if you want even
more comedy content joke world is also
on Twitter Instagram Facebook Spotify X
You Name It We got it thank you for
watching P joke
world that's did it
world and it world is wld
D that's a great uh YouTube channel joke
World check it out